This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. When they were teenagers, Ryan, Brown, and four of his friends decided to visit a really old graveyard. It was midnight, and they all piled onto an ATV belonging to his friend David. And this ATV is really just made for one person, so it's a vehicle with one big wheel in the front, two big wheels in the back, and David was driving. The rest of us were all kind of piled onto the back, sitting on top of the wheel guards. They took off down a dark country road. There are no street lights.
这里是 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。瑞安·布朗和他的四个朋友在十几岁时，决定去参观一个非常古老的墓园。当时正是午夜，他们全都挤在他朋友大卫的一辆全地形车上。这辆全地形车其实只适合一个人坐，前面有一个大轮子，后面有两个大轮子，是大卫在开。我们其他人基本上都挤在后面，坐在轮眉上。他们沿着一条黑暗的乡村公路出发了。那里没有路灯。
He's going about as fast as he possibly can, and nobody's wearing a helmet, so if we crash, we're all dead. Fearing for his life, Ryan spoke up and I said to David over the road noise, the engine noise, it would really be nice if you'd slow down a bit and he decided that was actually a great opportunity to turn off the headlights. opportunity to turn off the headlights. So we're on this dark country road, no lighting, no seatbelts, no helmets, Ryan Panicked.
他开得几乎和最快速度一样快，而且谁也没戴头盔，所以如果我们出车祸，我们就全完了。瑞安担心自己的生命安全，便开口说话了，我在路面噪音和发动机噪音中对大卫说，如果你能稍微开慢一点就好了，而他却觉得这其实是一个关掉前照灯的好机会。关掉前照灯的好机会。所以我们在黑暗的乡村公路上，没有灯光，没有安全带，没有头盔，瑞安惊慌失措。
I kind of freak out, I'm thinking, he's gonna kill us on the way to a graveyard, no less. So I start yelling at him, telling him he needs to slow down, and he just turned the lights back on. And he is having none of it. He feels threatened, he feels challenged. So by the time we get to the graveyard, I'm livid. I've been yelling at him for the past mile to slow down and turn on the lights.
我有点吓坏了，我想，他要在去墓园的路上害死我们，而且还不止如此。所以我开始对大卫大喊大叫，告诉他必须减速，然后他把车灯重新打开了。但他根本听不进去。他觉得自己受到了威胁，受到了挑衅。所以当我们到达墓园时，我已经怒不可遏了。在过去的一英里里，我一直在大喊大叫，让他减速并打开车灯。
And really after that weekend, we never really spoke much again. He was not able to apologize for his behavior. I sort of apologize for mine, but I really wasn't all that sorry. I felt like he'd taken my life and my friends' lives into his hands and treated them callously and thoughtlessly and recklessly. That story has stuck with Ryan, who went on to become a psychologist at Rice University in Texas. He now understands why his friend refused to back down. Over the past two weeks, we've looked at how stories help us explain the world and how
说实话，那个周末过后，我们基本上就再没怎么说过话了。他没能为自己的行为道歉。我算是为自己的行为道了歉，但我其实并没有那么抱歉。我觉得他把我和朋友们的生命当儿戏，冷酷无情、考虑不周且鲁莽妄为。这个故事一直留在瑞安的心中，他后来成了德克萨斯州莱斯大学的一名心理学家。他现在理解了为什么他的朋友拒绝退让。在过去的两个星期里，我们探讨了故事如何帮助我们解释世界以及
stories can help to heal the world. Today we examine how our societies give us stories that dictate what we can and cannot do. How cultural scripts shape our lives this week on Hidden Brain. The World Cup Final Hello everybody, welcome to the World Cup Final of 2006, the 18 years later and thousands of miles from the scene of that midnight ride in the ATV. France and Italy are battling it out in the finals of the World Cup soccer championship. They're playing in Berlin. More than 700 million people across the globe are watching. The game is very close. France scores first. Then Italy scores.
故事如何帮助治愈世界。今天我们探讨社会如何赋予我们规定我们能做什么和不能做什么的故事。文化剧本如何塑造我们的生活，本周 Hidden Brain 节目将为您播出。世界杯决赛 大家好，欢迎收看2006年世界杯决赛，这是在距离那次午夜全地形车之行18年后、远隔数千英里的地方。法国队和意大利队在世界杯足球赛决赛中展开殊死较量。比赛在柏林举行。全球有超过7.5亿人在观看比赛。比赛非常胶着。法国队率先破门。随后意大利队扳平比分。
The score is 1-1. We're just a few minutes left of the game. Something astonishing happens. Francis Captain and star player, Zinedine Zedan, violently knocks the Italian player Marco Matarazzi to the ground. Well, he's just headed Matarazzi in the middle of the chest. It's a flagrant foul. Zedan is ejected from the game.
比分变成了1比1。比赛只剩下最后几分钟了。令人震惊的事情发生了。法国队队长兼球星齐内丁·齐达内暴力将意大利球员马尔科·马特拉齐撞倒在地。好吧，他刚刚在胸口位置狠狠地撞了马特拉齐一下。这是一次恶意犯规。齐达内被罚出场。
Without its captain and star, France goes on to lose the match and lose the championship. And the showpiece of the World Game has an unsavory moment here. It will make the headlines beyond the results I feel. It did make headlines around the world. Everyone had a single question. Why did he do it? Why would someone, on the cusp of the greatest victory in his life, throw it all away?
在没有队长和球星的情况下，法国队输掉了比赛，也输掉了冠军。这场世界第一运动的巅峰之战在这里出现了一个不光彩的时刻。这将会成为超越比赛结果的头条新闻。它的确登上了世界各地的头条新闻。每个人心中都有一个共同的疑问。他为什么要这么做？为什么会有人在即将迎来人生中最伟大的胜利时，把这一切全都抛弃？
This was the dawn's final game of his career. He was the captain of the team, as you mentioned, representing France, although he was actually from Algeria. This again is Rice University psychologist, Ryan Brown. Throughout the match, he was kind of sparring with Marco Madarazzi from Italy. Yet you could tell that they were being a little physical with each other, they were exchanging words throughout, at one point. Madarazzi says something to him, nobody can tell, of course, watching what was said, but Zedon headbutts him in the chest. Now, nobody knew what had sparked this until a while later when Zedon was interviewed about
这是齐达内职业生涯的最后一场比赛。正如你所提到的，他是球队队长，代表法国参赛，尽管他实际上来自阿尔及利亚。再次采访的是莱斯大学心理学家瑞安·布朗。在整场比赛中，他一直与来自意大利的马尔科·马特拉齐有些针锋相对。然而你可以看出，他们之间有些身体接触，双方一直在互相对话，有一刻。马特拉齐对他说了一些话，当然，通过观看比赛谁也无法听清说的是什么，但齐达内用头撞了他的胸口。当时谁也不知道是什么引发了这一幕，直到后来齐达内接受采访
it and it turns out that Madata Razzi had insulted his sister. Zadon had said, after the game I'll give you my jersey as a souvenir. Mata Razzi replied that he'd rather have Zadon's sister's jersey. Clearly a suggestion of a sexual nature and Zadon couldn't handle it. Again, the French captain said he'd give the Italian his jersey after the game. He was implying France was going to win, and he would graciously give the Italian his jersey as a souvenir to remember the crushing defeat. The Italian player later recalled saying, I'd rather have your sister, the whore.
时才透露，马特拉齐侮辱了他的姐姐。齐达内曾说，赛后我会把球衣送给你作为纪念。马特拉齐回应说，他更想要齐达内姐姐的球衣。这显然带有某种性暗示，齐达内无法接受。这位法国队长再次表示，赛后会把球衣送给意大利球员。他是在暗示法国队会赢，而他会大度地把球衣送给意大利人作为纪念，让他们记住这场惨败。这位意大利球员后来回忆说，我更想要你那个当妓女的姐姐。
As hundreds of millions of people watched, Zinedine Zadan responded with a sudden burst of violence. About four years after this event, he was asked if he felt like he should apologize to Madhara Zanhee said he'd rather die than apologize. The French president Jacques Chirac weighed in on the incident. Far from bemoaning the loss of the world championship, he hailed Zinedine Zadan as a man of heart and conviction. Ryan Brown thinks there's a connection between what happened on that soccer field and what happened to him and his friends when they were teenagers. Even with the World Cup on the line, Zinnidin Zadan would not back down when he felt his family
在数亿观众的注视下，齐内丁·齐达内以一次突然的暴力爆发作出了回应。大约在这场事件发生四年后，当被问及是否觉得应该向马特拉齐道歉时，他说他宁死也不道歉。法国总统雅克·希拉克对这起事件发表了看法。他非但没有哀叹世界杯冠军的失利，反而称赞齐内丁·齐达内是一个有气魄、有信念的男人。瑞安·布朗认为，球场上发生的事情与他和朋友们十几岁时遭遇的事情之间存在某种联系。即使面临世界杯冠军的得失，当齐内丁·齐达内觉得自己的家人
was insulted. David would not back down even as he was risking his life and the lives of his friends. Both the soccer player and the teenager were following the gendered scripts of what Ryan calls an honor culture. Honor cultures are societies that put the defensive reputation at the center of social life and make that defense one of the highest priorities that people have.
受到侮辱时，他也绝不退缩。大卫即使在冒着自己和朋友生命危险的时候也绝不退缩。这位足球运动员和这个青少年都遵循着瑞安所说的荣誉文化的性别剧本。荣誉文化是指将捍卫名誉置于社会生活中心，并将这种捍卫视为人们最高优先级任务之一的社会。
So in each one of these cases, there was an element of defensive reputation driving people's behaviors. In the case of Zadan, his sister's virtue had been called into question by an opponent, and he felt he absolutely had to respond. He had no choice but to respond with aggression. In the case of my friend David, driving late at night, that sort of behavior, excessive risk-taking behavior to show how brave and tough you are, is an element of honor culture.
因此，在这些案例中，都存在着捍卫声誉这一驱动人们行为的因素。就齐达内而言，他的姐姐的美德受到了对手的质疑，他觉得绝对必须做出回应。他别无选择，只能以侵略性做出回应。就我的朋友大卫而言，深夜驾车出行，那种表现自己有多勇敢、多强硬的过度冒险行为，正是荣誉文化的一个组成部分。
It's a way of building your reputation. And furthermore, his inability to back down when confronted by me was another aspect of honor culture.'s very typical of people who are driven by honor-related beliefs and values. But all of us care about reputation, what's different about reputation in one of these honor cultures? Well, you're right. Every human being that's ever lived
这是建立声誉的一种方式。此外，当面对我的质问时，他无法退缩，这也是荣誉文化的一个方面。这非常典型地反映了那些受荣誉相关信仰和价值观驱使的人。但我们所有人都关照声誉，在这些荣誉文化中，声誉有什么不同之处呢？嗯，你说得对。曾经活过的每一个人类
cares about their reputation, they care about how other people see them. Honor cultures put this normal universal human concern on cultural steroids. And they also create a set of scripts or demands for how you should respond when your reputation is at risk. When your honor has been threatened, you have to respond in kind. You don't back down. If you ever back down, you'll be known as the kind of person who can be taken advantage of, who can be teased, who can be humiliated.
都关心自己的声誉，关心别人如何看待自己。荣誉文化把这种人类普遍存在的正常关切提升到了文化上的“兴奋剂”水平。它们还为当你的声誉面临危险时你应该如何反应制定了一套剧本或要求。当你的荣誉受到威胁时，你必须以牙还牙地做出回应。你不能退缩。如果你曾经退缩，你就会被认为是一个可以被占便宜、可以被嘲弄、可以被羞辱的人。
You can't have that in an honor culture. You see that honor cultures are more likely to thrive in communities that are small or rural. In a small town, as you say, everyone knows your name and everyone knows your shame. That's right. So smaller communities seem like on the face of it, they should be safer communities because everybody knows everybody. And there are ways in which that might be true. But if that smaller community exists within an honor culture, then the fact that everybody
在荣誉文化中，这是绝对不被允许的。你会发现，荣誉文化更有可能在规模较小或乡村的社区中蓬勃发展。正如你所说，在小镇里，每个人都知道你的名字，每个人也都知道你的丑事。没错。因此，表面上看，较小的社区似乎应该更安全，因为每个人都认识每个人。在某些方面确实如此。但如果这个小社区存在于荣誉文化之中，那么每个人
knows who you are can be problematic for you, at least in the case when your honor has been threatened, when you have been humiliated, when you have failed in some public way, and everybody knows about it. So you're the opposite of a safe. In a larger community, in a big city, you might have the same failure experience, but you can walk down the street
都认识你这一点可能会给你带来麻烦，至少在你的荣誉受到威胁、受到羞辱、在某个公开场合失败并且人尽皆知的情况下是这样的。所以你恰恰与安全相反。在一个较大的社区，比如大城市里，你可能会经历同样的失败，但你可以走在街上
and be relatively anonymous. That's not true in a small town. If those smaller communities are situated within honor cultures. Are you yourself a product of an honor culture, Ryan? I am, and I knew that when I began this research on honor cultures, but I didn't actually realize the extent to which it was true. In the United States, at least, a lot of the roots of our honor-related beliefs and values come to us from immigrants from southern Scotland, people who were broadly known as the Scots Irish or Scotch Irish. And so it turns out my own people, my own
并且保持相对的匿名。小镇可就不是这样了。如果这些小社区身处荣誉文化之中。瑞安，你自己也是荣誉文化的产物吗？是的，当我开始这项关于荣誉文化的调研时我就知道这一点，但我其实并没有意识到它真实的程度有多深。在美国，至少我们很多与荣誉相关的信仰和价值观的根源，都来自于苏格兰南部的移民，也就是被广泛称为苏格兰-爱尔兰裔或苏格兰爱尔兰裔的人群。所以事实证明，我自己的族人，我父亲那边的
forebears on my father's side are Scottish immigrants. Largely because of where they settled in the US, we can see the residue of these unrelated beliefs and values that they brought with them in states primarily in the south and in the west. In the north and northern Midwest, there were actually different groups of immigrants that came over from England, from the Netherlands, from Germany, from Sweden, and all these different immigrant groups brought their own beliefs and values with them. And to some extent, those beliefs and values remained intact within communities. And so in communities and in the southern colonies, when the US was not quite the United States yet,
祖先其实就是苏格兰移民。很大程度上由于他们在美洲定居的地点，我们可以在主要位于南部和西部的各州中看到他们带来的这些与荣誉相关的信仰和价值观的残余。在北部和中北部地区，实际上有来自英国、荷兰、德国、瑞典的不同移民群体，所有这些不同的移民群体都带来了他们自己的信仰和价值观。在某种程度上，这些信仰和价值观在社区内部保持完好。因此，在美利坚合众国尚未完全成形的南部社区和南部殖民地中，
those beliefs and values of those Scottish immigrants really came to dominate the cultures of these southern colonies, eventually southern states. And because these Scottish immigrants came over with their families, which was unusual for transatlantic immigration at the time, they were essentially able to outbreed all these other groups that settled in the South. And so their norms and their values that they brought over with them really came to dominate the communities, the cultures of the Southern colonies, the Southern states. Then they push West. And so if you think
这些苏格兰移民的信仰和价值观真正主导了南部殖民地乃至后来的南部各州的文化。由于这些苏格兰移民是带着家庭一同迁徙的——这在当时的跨大西洋移民中并不常见，他们基本上在繁衍上压倒了所有其他在南部定居的群体。因此，他们带来的规范和价值观真正主导了南部殖民地和南部各州的社区与文化。然后他们向西推进。所以如果你回想
about Westerns, if you think about Western movies or Western history, there are always rough and tumble guys with names that sound kind of Scottish, a mech-tavish, McDonald, McDougall, Graham, etc. And that's not an accident. So even today, even though most people in the US in the South don't think of themselves as byproducts of Scottish history, you can still see this cultural residue in some fairly powerful patterns of social life that social scientists, many others, including myself, have documented over the last 20 years. on our culture and military valor. Can you talk about that at a moment? What is the relationship, for example, between the states that have a high on our culture and states that don't, and military success or military valor? Well, several years ago, my colleagues and I
西部片，回想西部电影或西部历史，总会有那些粗犷彪悍的家伙，名字听起来有点像苏格兰人，比如麦克塔维什、麦克唐纳、麦克杜格尔、格雷姆等等。这并非偶然。所以即使在今天，尽管美国南部的大多数人不认为自己是苏格兰历史的副产品，你仍然可以在过去20年里由社会科学家以及包括我在内的许多其他人记录的一些相当强有力的社会生活模式中看到这种文化残余。我们的文化与军事英勇。你能谈谈这个吗？例如，拥有高荣誉文化的州与没有这种文化的州，在军事成功或军事英勇之间有什么关系？嗯，几年前，我和我的同事们
looked at the recipients of the Congressional Medal of Honor for soldiers that fought during World War II. So we examined these recipients and what we found is that soldiers who came from honor states in the US, South, and West were significantly more likely to have won the congressional medal of honor than soldiers who came from other states. Now, let me be clear, Valor can be exhibited by anyone. Men, women, white, black, it doesn't matter where you're from or who you are. But the important thing was that in this study that people who came from honor states seem to be more likely to engage in the sorts of behaviors that would be recognized as Valorous, which often meant they lost their own lives,
研究了在第二次世界大战期间作战的士兵所获得的国会荣誉勋章得主。我们对这些获奖者进行了研究，发现来自美国南部和西部荣誉州的士兵，比来自其他州的士兵更有可能赢得国会荣誉勋章。现在，我要澄清一点，英勇精神可以由任何人表现出来。男人、女人、白人、黑人，你来自哪里或你是谁并不重要。但重要的是，在这项研究中，来自荣誉州的士兵似乎更有可能从事那些会被认为是英勇的行为，这通常意味着他们失去了生命，
or at least risked their own lives for their comrades. And this is an element of, again, the kind of reputation that you want to build if you're a man living in an honor culture. You're strong, brave, and loyal that you take care of the people around you. You defend them even as you would defend yourself, even at the risk of your own life. Show encourage even when your own life is at stake and protecting the people around you. These might seem like inherently positive traits, but groups that are intent on defending their honor can also get trapped in endless cycles of violence and retribution.
或者至少为了战友冒着生命危险。这也是如果你生活在荣誉文化中的男性想要建立的那种声誉的组成部分。你坚强、勇敢、忠诚，照顾你身边的人。你保护他们，就像保护自己一样，甚至甘冒生命危险。在保护周围人的过程中表现出勇气，即使生命处于危急关头。这些可能看起来是天生积极的特质，但一心想要捍卫荣誉的群体也可能陷入无休止的暴力和报复循环中。
To be clear, honor cultures are widespread across the globe. They can be found in many countries in Latin America, Asia, and Africa. They can also be found in black and brown communities in the United States. They are particularly prevalent in the US, South and West. Drive through states like Alabama, Oklahoma, and Texas, and you can see honor culture reflected, even in the names of towns and businesses. The research of Michael Kelly found a family in Alabama could have their television service at warrior electronics, their dog housed at Guntoke Kennels, their home edition built by bullet construction, and their children taught at Battleground School. One of my favorite examples I actually ran into, kind of literally, as I was driving through
需要明确的是，荣誉文化在全球范围广泛存在。它们可以在拉丁美洲、亚洲和非洲的许多国家找到。它们也可以在美国的黑人和棕色人种社区中找到。它们在美国南部和西部尤为普遍。开车穿过阿拉巴马州、俄克拉荷马州和得克萨斯州等州，你甚至可以从城镇和企业的名称中看到荣誉文化的反映。迈克尔·凯利的研究发现，阿拉巴马州的一个家庭可以在“战士电子”享受电视服务，他们的狗住在“枪声犬舍”，他们的房屋由“子弹建筑”加建，他们的孩子则在“战场学校”接受教育。我遇到的最喜欢的例子之一其实是一次巧合，当我开车穿过
Texas many years ago, trying to take a shortcut back between Alabama and Oklahoma, where I was living at the time. And we were going through all these back country roads until we came upon this little town called Cut and Shoot Texas. And we stopped on the side of the road to take a picture of the sign as a Cut and Shoot Texas. So who names a town? Not one violent image, but two, cut and shoot. In case we don't get you with one,
德克萨斯州时，试图抄近路返回当时我居住的阿拉巴马州和俄克拉荷马州之间。我们穿行于各种乡间小路，直到来到一个叫作“砍杀得克萨斯”（Cut and Shoot）的小镇。我们在路边停下来，给“砍杀得克萨斯”的招牌拍了张照片。什么样的人会给一个小镇起这样的名字？不是一个暴力意象，而是两个，砍和杀。万一一个没镇住你，
we'll get you with the other. And research has found that businesses and town names that contain some kind of violent imagery are much more common in honor states than in non-honor states in the US. Place names are only one small example of the many ways in which honor culture shapes the lives of millions of people. When we come back, the surprising origins of honor culture and the profound ways it shapes who we are and how we vote. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Ryan Brown is a psychologist at Rice University.
另一个也会镇住你。研究发现，包含某种暴力意象的企业和城镇名称在美国的荣誉州比在非荣誉州要普遍得多。地名只是荣誉文化塑造数百万人生活的众多例子中的一个微小缩影。稍后我们将为您带来：荣誉文化的惊人起源，以及它如何深刻塑造了我们是谁以及我们如何投票。欢迎收听 Hidden Brain，我是香卡·维丹塔姆。瑞安·布朗是莱斯大学的心理学家。
He is the author of Honor Bound, How a Cultural Idea Has Shaped the American Psychie. Ryan Honor Cultures don't just spring out of nowhere. You say there are very specific conditions that tend to produce these cultures. What are those conditions? The conditions that social scientists believe spawn honor cultures are fallen to really two main categories. The first is that economically people have to feel insecure. That kind of insecurity at an economic level often coincides with poverty, but it's more than just poverty. It's the instability. You've got to feel uncertain about whether or not you will survive economically the next season, the next year, and combined with that economic insecurity,
他是《坚守荣誉：文化理念如何塑造美国心理》（Honor Bound: How a Cultural Idea Has Shaped the American Psyche）一书的作者。瑞安，荣誉文化并非凭空出现。你说有非常特定的条件往往会产生这些文化，这些条件是什么？社会科学家认为孕育荣誉文化的条件大致分为两大类。首先是人们在经济上必须感到不安全。经济层面的这种不 insecurity 通常与贫困相吻合，但它不仅仅是贫困。它是动荡。你必须对自己在经济上是否能在下个季度、下一年生存下来感到不确定，而在这种经济不安全感之外，
there's a sense of the unreliability of law enforcement. So what we refer to as the rule of law is not very strong. When these two things coincide, that makes threats, social threats, especially important. If somebody comes and steals your cattle, threatens your family, you know that nobody's coming to save you. That's it for you. And so, reputation is incredibly important. You want to have a reputation as someone that nobody should mess with. They're going to think twice before messing with you or your stuff or your family, because they know that you're going to respond with you or your stuff or your family because they know that you're going to respond aggressively and violently. And that sort of reputation protects you.
还伴随着一种执法不可靠的感觉。因此，我们所说的法治并不强大。当这两者同时存在时，威胁——尤其是社会威胁——就变得格外重要。如果有人来偷你的牛，威胁你的家人，你知道没有人会来救你。只能靠你自己。因此，声誉变得极其重要。你希望树立起一种“谁也惹不起”的声誉。在招惹你、你的物品或你的家人之前，他们会三思而后行，因为他们知道你会用
Yeah, and it's important to flag here that it's not just a culture of violence because in fact honor cultures don't necessarily endorse people acting violently toward one another with no provocation. It's responding violently or aggressively in the face of threat or the face of some kind of an effort to exploit you. That's right. Honor cultures, for example, are often very polite cultures, but something that Dave Cohen has referred to as the paradox of politeness is that these politeness norms coincide with norms associated with responding aggressively to honor threats. So, for example, in the US South, it's a very polite place. It's where I grew up in Alabama.
是的，这里需要指出的是，这不仅仅是一种暴力文化，因为事实上荣誉文化并不一定赞成人们在毫无挑衅的情况下互相采取暴力行动。而是在面对威胁或某种剥削努力时，以暴力或攻击性做出回应。没错。例如，荣誉文化通常是非常礼貌的文化，但戴夫·科恩所说的“礼貌悖论”是，这些礼貌规范与对荣誉威胁做出攻击性反应的规范相吻合。例如，美国南部是一个非常礼貌的地方。我在阿拉巴马州长大，那里就是这样。
You learn to say, yes, ma'am, and no sir, and please, and thank you, and pardon me. But once you cross me, you cross a certain line, I'm going to kill you then. One of us is going to die. This is the paradox is that you have this politeness that goes hand in hand with this sensitivity to threat. And the problem, of course, is that if you have a sensitivity to threat, although you're not always walking around behaving aggressively toward people, what it takes to set you off isn't very much.
你学会了说“好的，女士”、“不用了，先生”、“请”、“谢谢”和“对不起”。但一旦你惹了我，越过了一定界限，我当时就会杀了你。我们俩中得死一个。这就是悖论：你既拥有这种礼貌，又同时对威胁保持着高度敏感。当然，问题在于，如果你对威胁敏感，尽管你并不总是四处对人表现得充满攻击性，但要激怒你并不需要付出太多。
It could be as little as you're looking at me. You're talking to me. Exactly. Now you've got to respond. And then I have to respond. And who the hell are you talking to me? So yes, I technically didn't start the fight, but it didn't take very much to get me into it either. Now someone could say, you know, things that happened in the long ago past, what do they have to do with the present? So you mentioned immigration patterns of the Scott's Irish to the United States, for example. But you know, things that happen in the long ago past, what do they have to do with the present? So you mentioned immigration patterns of the Scots Irish to the United States, for example, but you know, what is the culture of Scotland in, you know, 15, 16, 17th century, have to do with the culture in South Carolina in the 21st century? Can you talk a moment about the power that culture has to get passed down, even into
可能仅仅是因为你看了我一眼。你跟我说话了。没错。现在你必须做出回应。然后我必须回应。你特么到底在跟谁说话？所以，是的，我技术上并没有挑起这场争端，但要卷入其中也并不需要费多大劲。现在有人可能会说，很久以前发生的事情，跟现在有什么关系呢？所以你提到了苏格兰-爱尔兰人移民到美国的模式，但是呢，很久以前发生的事情，跟现在有什么关系呢？所以你提到了苏格兰-爱尔兰人移民到美国的模式，但是呢，15、16、17世纪的苏格兰文化，跟21世纪的南卡罗来纳州文化有什么关系呢？你能谈谈文化能够代代相传的力量吗，甚至在
context where the original environment that created the culture no longer exists. Yes, that is a really important question, I think, because it's easy to look at these origins of honor, culture, beliefs, and values and say, well, that doesn't describe us today. That's not my people, that's not my family, that's not my community. But it doesn't have to be, and that's the power of social norms. That's the power of these beliefs and values that are rooted in our definitions of self. What does it mean to be a person of value? In an honor culture, what it means to be a person of value is that you are the kind of person who's lived up to the demands of what it means to be a real man or a good woman.
最初创造这种文化的原始环境已经不复存在的背景下。是的，这是一个非常重要的问题，我认为，因为很容易看着荣誉文化、信仰和价值观的这些起源说，嗯，那不描述今天的我们。那不是我的人民，那不是我的家庭，那不是我的社区。但它不一定非得是，这就是社会规范的力量。这就是扎根于我们自我定义的这些信仰 and 价值观的力量。作为一个有价值的人意味着什么？在荣誉文化中，作为一个有价值的人意味着你是一个活出“真正的男人”或“好女人”要求标准的人。
In other cultures, that we sometimes refer to as dignity cultures, a person has value, they have worth because they're a human being. So of course, there's differences in reputation, differences even in social status, but there's a degree to which you can never fully lose your worth if you live in a dignity culture. In an honor culture, you have to maintain these standards. You have to live up to these standards of being a real man or a good woman. And if you don't, you could lose your value altogether and never get it back. Ryan and his colleague Jennifer Barnes have explored how American movies
在有时被称为尊严文化的其他文化中，一个人有价值、有尊严是因为他们是人类。所以，当然，声誉存在差异，社会地位也存在差异，但在某种程度上，如果你生活在尊严文化中，你永远不会完全失去你的尊严。而在荣誉文化中，你必须维护这些标准。你必须达到做真正的男人或好女人的这些标准。如果你做不到，你可能会彻底失去你的价值，并且再也找不回来。瑞安和他的同事詹妮弗·巴恩斯探讨了美国电影
have long valorized honor cultures. There's the Princess Bride, my name is Inyegomantaya, you kill my father, prepare for die. Dori Harry, go ahead, make my day. And of course, the Godfather. Whatever I have done to make you take me so disrespectfully. These movies frequently teach people and reinforce the themes that are associated with honor-related beliefs and values. So themes of retaliation, for example, are incredibly common in these very popular films.
长期以来如何美化荣誉文化。比如《公主新娘》中的台词：“我叫伊尼戈·蒙托亚，你杀了我父亲，准备受死吧。”《肮脏的哈利》：“来吧，让我的日子好过点。”当然还有《教父》：“无论我做了什么，让你如此不尊重我……”这些电影频繁地教导人们并强化与荣誉相关的信仰和价值观的主题。因此，例如复仇的主题在这些非常受欢迎的电影中极为常见。
And kids' movies, superhero movies, even some animated films, were the most likely to exhibit these honor-related themes. Again, they weren't directly about honor. They didn't always say honor and reputation, but they were about this idea of retaliation for wrongdoing. You stand up to the bad guy. You stand up to the bully and you fight. You don't back down. And so this is one of the ways that we see these beliefs and values kind of subtly, I think, being reinforced in contemporary times. You see it in music as well, country music, I think, is especially prevalent where we talk about what it means to be a real man or a good woman. Stand by your men
儿童电影、超级英雄电影，甚至一些动画电影，最有可能展现这些与荣誉相关的主题。同样，它们并不直接关于荣誉。它们并不总是把荣誉和声誉挂在嘴边，但它们关乎因遭受不义对待而进行报复的想法。你挺身而出对抗坏人。你站出来对抗恶霸并与之战斗。你绝不退缩。所以这是我们看到这些信仰和价值观在当代以微妙方式得到强化的一种方式。你在音乐中也能看到这一点，乡村音乐我认为尤其普遍，其中我们谈论了做一个真正的男人或好女人意味着什么。至死不渝
If you're too long to find them I'll make the aerial airborne But baby, I'll make real good things And so these beliefs and values really stick around for a long time Long after the social conditions that created them have disappeared into the past. Ryan first got interested in honor culture because of a study of homicides conducted by Richard Nisbert and his colleagues. In his book, Ryan describes what happens during argument-based homicides. What Nizbitt and his colleagues found early on was that, first of all, argument-based homicides
如果你找他们太久，我会让空中力量介入，但宝贝，我会把事情做得很好。因此，这些信仰 and 价值观确实能保留很长时间，远远超出了创造它们的社会条件在过去消失的时间。瑞安最初对荣誉文化产生兴趣，是因为理查德·尼斯贝特及其同事对凶杀案的一项研究。瑞安在书中描述了基于争执的凶杀案发生时的情景。尼斯贝特及其同事早期发现的是，首先，基于争执的凶杀案
are one of the most common forms of homicide in the US. So they start with what police typically refer to as a trivial altercation. You're in a bar, perhaps. You've been drinking a little bit, and you notice somebody at the table next to you Who's kind of looking at you funny? And so at some point you make eye contact you lock eyes and you say are you looking at me? And maybe they respond you know with some glib comment About why they'd be looking at you you're too ugly to look at or no
是美国最常见的凶杀形式之一。所以它们始于警察通常所说的微不足道的争吵。也许你正在酒吧里。你喝了一点酒，注意到你邻桌有个人正在用奇怪的眼神打量你？于是在某个时刻你们有了眼神接触，四目相对，你问：“你在看我吗？”也许他们会回应一些油腔滑调的评论，
I was looking at your sister or some comment like like that. And it escalates, and now you have to respond. So it began with something that was nothing, a trivial altercation. And because in an honor culture, you can't stand somebody insulting your honor, you can't just sit there and take it. It escalates, and each party tries to one up the other. And eventually you wind up in the parking lot, and somebody is lying on the ground in a pool of blood. And it usually happens in a public setting where whatever you do or don't do
关于他们为什么看你——你长得太丑了不值得看，或者“不，我在看你姐姐”诸如此类的话。冲突随之升级，现在你必须做出回应。所以它始于一件微不足道的小事，一次无谓的争吵。而在荣誉文化中，你无法忍受别人侮辱你的荣誉，你不能只是坐在那里逆来顺受。矛盾升级，双方都试图压对方一头。最终你们以在停车场大打出手收场，一个人倒在血泊中。这种情况通常发生在公共场合，无论你做什么或不做什么
will be known by the people around you. So again, your reputation is at stake. And these sorts of homicides, unlike other forms of homicide, like homicides that are committed in the midst of a robbery, for example, these argument- like homicides that are committed in the midst of a robbery, for example. These argument-based homicides are much more common in honor-oriented states than in non-honor states in the U.S. Researchers have conducted experiments to see how threats to reputation can quickly
都会被周围的人所知。所以再次强调，你的声誉危在旦关。这类凶杀案与其他形式的凶杀案不同，例如在抢劫过程中实施的凶杀案，这种基于争执的凶杀案在美国的荣誉州比在非荣誉州要常见得多。研究人员通过实验来观察声誉受到的威胁如何能迅速
escalate. In one study, men from the southern United States, where there is a strong honor culture, and men from the northern United States, where honor culture is less strong, were insulted by an actor. The actor then disappeared behind a locked door. The volunteers in the experiment were then made to walk down a narrow corridor that was lined with chairs. So right after being insulted, they're walking down this
升级。在一项研究中，来自美国南部（拥有强烈荣誉文化）的男性和来自美国北部（荣誉文化较弱）的男性被一名演员侮辱了。随后演员消失在一扇锁着的门后。接着，实验中的志愿者被迫走过一条铺满椅子的狭窄走廊。所以就在刚被侮辱之后，他们又走过这道
long narrow hallway again lined with chairs. Only one person can walk down at a time. And there's a large person walking in the opposite direction toward them. And now they have a dilemma to get out of this person's way, which they're going to have to do because he's enormous. He's like a football player, a linebacker. They're going to get out of this way, but to do so, they're going to have to kind of awkwardly turn to the side, sit or stand on the chairs, and it's essentially a game of chicken. Now, what do you do if you're from an honor culture, and you feel your honor has been threatened? You're going to go toe to toe with this guy. So, the researchers were actually measuring the distance between these two people, the linebacker and
长而狭窄、两边摆满椅子的走廊。一次只能通过一个人。迎面走来一个大块头。现在他们面临一个两难境地：要不要给这个人让路——他们肯定得让，因为他太庞大了。他就像个橄榄球运动员、线卫一样。他们得让路，但要做到这一点，他们必须尴尬地侧身，坐在或靠在椅子上，这基本上是一场“胆小鬼博弈”。那么，如果你来自荣誉文化，并且觉得自己的荣誉受到了威胁，你会怎么做？你会跟这家伙针锋相对。因此，研究人员实际上是在测量这两个人之间的距离——那个线卫和
the insulted participant, to see how close the participants let this guy get before they finally got out of his way. And again, they always got out of his way. There was no choice. The Southern participants who were not insulted previously, so there was no honor threat, were extremely gracious, extremely polite. And they were actually likely to turn and get out of the guy's way much earlier than the northern participants, the ones that grew up in non-honor states. But after an insult,
受到侮辱的参与者——以观察参与者在最终让路之前让这家伙靠近到什么程度。话说回来，他们总是会让路的。别无选择。此前没有受到侮辱的南方参与者（因此没有荣誉威胁）表现得极其亲切、极其礼貌。事实上，与北方参与者（在非荣誉州长大的人）相比，他们更有可能提早转身给对方让路。但在遭到侮辱之后，
the southern participants went toe-to-toe with this guy. They're going to get out of his way. They can't help it. They're going to have to. But they get right up next to him, because they're demonstrating that they're tough. They're not afraid They're real men and subsequent studies that use the same sort of paradigm actually showed that these southern males after being insulted experienced spikes in testosterone and cortisol so that they had higher levels of hormones that were associated with both stress and social competition
南方参与者与这家伙针锋相对。他们会给对方让路。他们情非得已，必须得让。但他们会紧贴着对方走过去，因为他们在证明自己很强硬。他们不害怕，他们是真正的男人。随后的研究采用相同的范式，实际上表明这些南方男性在受到侮辱后，体内的睾酮和皮质醇水平飙升，这意味着他们血液中流淌着与压力和社交竞争相关的高水平荷尔蒙。
coursing through their bloodstreams. So there's something that ties together many of the examples we've discussed Ryan whether that's violence on a soccer field or teenage boys behaving recklessly or games of chicken It does seem like there's a connection between honor culture and masculinity. Well, I've said already that honor cultures put the defensive reputation at the center of social life, and that leads to the question, what kind of reputation? What sort of reputation do you want to build and then maintain if you live in an honor culture? And the answer to that question depends upon whether you're a man or a woman. So if you're a real man in an honor culture, then that means you've built a reputation as someone who's strong, tough, brave, loyal, and utterly intolerant
因此，瑞安，我们讨论过的许多例子之间都有着某种联系，无论是球场上的暴力、少年的鲁莽行为，还是胆小鬼博弈。荣誉文化与男子气概之间似乎确实存在某种联系。好吧，我之前已经说过，荣誉文化将捍卫声誉置于社会生活中心，这就引发了一个问题：究竟是什么样的声誉？如果你生活在荣誉文化中，你想建立并维护什么样的声誉？这个问题的答案取决于你是男人还是女人。所以，如果你是荣誉文化中的一个真正的男人，那就意味着你树立了一种坚强、强硬、勇敢、忠诚且对不尊重行为
of disrespect. If you're a woman in an honor culture and you're considered a good woman and honorable woman, that means that you've lived up to the social standards that say you should be loyal to family, especially loyal to your husband, and sexually pure. So imagine a situation in which you have a couple, they could be a married couple, or they could be dating, and the man feels like the woman has been flirting with another man. And so he confronts her about it because this is a threat to his honor. Are you disrespecting me? Are you suggesting that you can just behave that way with other men?
绝对零容忍的声誉。如果你是荣誉文化中的女性，并且被认为是一个好女人、有荣誉的女人，这就意味着你达到了这样的社会标准：你应该忠于家庭，尤其是忠于你的丈夫，并且在性方面保持纯洁。所以想象这样一种情况：有一对伴侣，他们可能是夫妻，也可能在约会，而男方觉得女方一直在和另一个男人调情。于是他质问她，因为这构成了对他荣誉的威胁。你是在不尊重我吗？你是在暗示你可以和其他男人有这种行为，
And I'm not going to notice or I'm not going to care. So that might be the beginning of a pattern that is similar to what we talked about before with the trivial altercation. Begins with something small. It might just be a look. It might be a laugh, a giggle at another person's joke. And the man feels disrespected. He's suspicious. He's worried about his reputation. And so it escalates from there. And what we found is that domestic homicide rates in the US are significantly higher among white males in honor states compared to white males in non-honor states. And what we found is that women who endorse the beliefs and values of honor feel like those acts of jealousy and anger and even aggression and control
而我不会察觉或者我根本不在乎吗？这可能是一种模式的开始，类似于我们之前讨论过的微不足道的争吵。它始于一件小事。可能只是一个眼神。可能是对别人笑话的一声轻笑、咯咯笑。而男人觉得受到了不尊重。他疑心重重。他担心自己的声誉。于是矛盾从这里开始升级。我们发现，在美国，荣誉州白人男性的家庭凶杀率显著高于非荣誉州白人男性的家庭凶杀率。我们还发现，那些认同荣誉信仰和价值观的女性认为，嫉妒、愤怒甚至攻击和控制的行为
are signs that the man is invested in her and that he loves her and he cares about her. So you can see why this sort of norm might get perpetuated is the kind of thing that could elevate me in the eyes of others and the eyes of women that I show this pattern of aggressive control of my woman in a relationship. There was a disturbing study by Joseph Vandallo and Dove Cohen in which they staged a fight between a couple in a waiting room, and the fight was partly designed to figure out how someone watching it would respond.
是一个男人对她投入、爱她并且在乎她的表现。所以你可以明白为什么这种规范可能会得以延续，因为当我展现出对恋爱中女人的这种攻击性控制模式时，这会在其他人以及女性眼中提升我的地位。约瑟夫·范达洛（Joseph Vandallo）和多夫·科恩（Dove Cohen）做过一项令人不安的研究，他们在候诊室里安排了一场情侣间的争吵，这场争吵部分旨在弄清楚旁观者会如何反应。
Can you describe the experiment to me and what they found? In this particular experiment, the researchers had women from honor-oriented cultures or non-honor cultures who were sitting in a waiting room waiting to participate in the study. And as they're sitting there, there's another woman sitting next to them. And at some point, her boyfriend apparently comes into the waiting room and a cosser. And there's a different scenario depending on the condition of the study that the people are in. In one scenario, he accost her for sort of random reasons, having nothing to do with honor and the other scenario, he accost her for reasons that are associated with his masculine pride with his honor.
你能向我描述一下这个实验以及他们的发现吗？在这项特定的实验中，研究人员让来自荣誉导向文化或非荣誉文化的女性坐在候诊室里等待参与实验。当她们坐在那里时，旁边还坐着另一位女性。在某个时刻，她的男朋友显然进入了候诊室并对她恶言相向。根据人们所处的实验条件，会有不同的剧本情景。在一个情景中，他以某种随机的原因对她恶言相向，这与荣誉毫无关系；在另一个情景中，他攻击她的原因与他的男子气概和荣誉有关。
And at the end of this confrontation, he actually shoves the young woman up against the wall, threatens her, and then storms off. And the researchers are actually looking at how the real participant responds to the young woman who's been accosted by her boyfriend. And women from an honor culture who witnessed this confrontation, if it were based on an honor-related threat to the guy, they were basically telling her it'll be okay. You should play Kate Hems, stay in the relationship, they were basically telling her it'll be okay, you should play Kate Hems, stay in the
在这场对峙结束时，他甚至将年轻女性推向墙壁，威胁她，然后气冲冲地离开。研究人员实际上在观察真实的参与者如何对这位遭到男友恶言相向的年轻女性做出反应。目睹了这场对峙、且如果事件基于对男性的荣誉相关威胁的荣誉文化女性，基本上会告诉她“一切都会好起来的。你应该安抚他、维持这段关系”，她们基本上会告诉她“一切都会好起来的，你应该安抚他、维持这段
relationship, etc. And this is really important going back to your comment, Shankar. In any kind of culture, we care about what others think, and this is another way in which honor-related beliefs and values get transmitted and taught. Even when people are not explicitly using the word honor or reputation. We still learn what's important to the people around us, what sort of behaviors we're supposed to engage in in order to be respected in order to have high status and to be valued by everybody else. One of the things that's really intriguing about this body of work, Ryan, is how you can see the same psychological dynamics at play in different countries, in very different contexts.
关系”等等。回到你的评论，香卡，这真的很重要。在任何一种文化中，我们都在乎别人的看法，这是荣誉相关的信仰 and 价值观得以传播和教导的另一种方式。即使人们没有明确使用“荣誉”或“声誉”这个词。我们仍然会了解到对身边的人来说什么才是重要的，为了受到尊重、获得高地位并被其他人看重，我们应该参与什么样的行为。瑞安，这项研究最引人入胜的地方之一，就是你能看到相同的心理动态在不同的国家、在截然不同的语境中发挥作用。
The psychologist Anna Costanza Baldry-Ren, a study with police officers in Afghanistan, where the officers were presented different scenarios of domestic violence. Do you remember what scenarios the officers were shown and how they reacted? The important thing to remember to begin with is that Afghanistan is a very honor-oriented culture. It may be the most honor-oriented culture in the world. So these police officers responding to an assault situation, a domestic violence situation, if an officer is called in to respond to a domestic dispute, shows up, and the husband, the boyfriend,
心理学家安娜·科斯坦扎·巴尔德里（Anna Costanza Baldry）在阿富汗对女警官（注：原文称警察，此处按泛指）进行了一项研究，向这些警官展示了不同的家庭暴力情景。你还记得警官们被展示了什么情景以及他们的反应吗？首先需要记住的重要一点是，阿富汗是一个高度崇尚荣誉的文化。它可能是世界上最崇尚荣誉的文化。因此，这些警察在应对攻击情况、家庭暴力情况时，如果接到报警去处理家庭纠纷，赶到现场后，丈夫、男朋友——
or even the ex-husband or boyfriend, is claiming that the woman has been unfaithful, the officer might downplay it, might not arrest the man, might even leave the couple to work it out on their own and say, oh, this is a personal matter, I don't need to respond. So it's a very important phenomenon in which the way that we construe a domestic violence situation
甚至前夫或前男友坚称这名女性不忠时，警官也可能会轻描淡写，可能不会逮捕这名男子，甚至可能让这对夫妇自己解决，并说，哦，这是一件私事，我不需要回应。所以这是一个非常重要的现象，我们对家庭暴力情况的理解方式
is affected profoundly by the extent to which we believe in and embrace the values of honor culture. So Ryan, we've talked about different ways in which an honor culture gets passed down, you know, in books or movies in the ways in which people respond to our stories and the ways in which a police officer might respond to something that he or she sees. But honor cultures are also enshrined in laws, in state laws that are on the books. Can you talk a moment about how, in some ways, the ideology of honor cultures show up in laws, for example, like stand your ground where very explicitly
受到我们对荣誉文化价值观的信仰和接受程度的深刻影响。所以，瑞恩，我们讨论了荣誉文化世代相传的不同方式，比如在书籍或电影中，人们对我们故事的回应方式，以及警察对其所见事物可能做出的回应方式。但荣誉文化也被铭刻在法律中，铭刻在现行的州法律中。你能谈谈荣誉文化的意识形态在多大程度上体现在法律中吗，例如“不退让法”（Stand Your Ground），其中非常明确地
you're told you can act in your own self-defense if you feel like you are, you are under threat. Yeah. St. Andrew Groundlaws are a legal extension of the castle doctrine. The castle doctrine goes back to English common law and it basically says, a person's castle is their home and they can defend that home, that castle, even by taking someone's life. So if somebody breaks into your home, you can kill them according to the castle doctrine and it's not murder, it's the defensive home. And so stand your ground laws, extend that castle doctrine to not just your home, but any place where you're legally allowed to be. So, rather than being required to retreat when confronted by an aggressive person who might look dangerous, might be dangerous, might even have a weapon,
告诉你可以出于自卫采取行动，如果你觉得自己受到了威胁。是的，“不退让法”是城堡法（Castle Doctrine）的法律延伸。“城堡法”可以追溯到英国普通法，它基本上指出，一个人的城堡就是他们的家，他们可以保卫这个家，这个城堡，甚至不惜夺走某人的生命。因此，如果有人闯入你的家，根据城堡法，你可以杀死他们，这不算谋杀，这是保卫家园。因此，“不退让法”将这种城堡法扩展到不仅仅是你的家，还包括任何你合法可以呆的地方。因此，面对一个可能看起来很危险、可能很危险、甚至可能拥有武器的具有攻击性的人时，你不需要被迫撤退，
you don't have to retreat, according to stand your ground laws, you can stand where you are and defend yourself. And if you assault that person, if you even kill that person, it's not considered murder. It's not even considered assault. It's considered self-defense. And different states have different orientations towards stand-your-ground laws. Some of them don't call them that. And what you see looking around the US is that the vast majority of states with stand-your-ground laws are in honor states as opposed to dignity states. So these laws, again, allow people to live up to the expectations of an honor culture by not retreating
根据“不退让法”，你不必撤退，你可以站在原地保护自己。如果你袭击了那个人，甚至杀死了那个人，这也不被认为是谋杀。它甚至不被认为是袭击。它被认为是正当防卫。不同的州对“不退让法”有不同的取向。其中一些州不这样称呼它。你在美国各地看到的是，绝大多数拥有“不退让法”的州都是荣誉州，而不是尊严州。因此，这些法律再次允许人们通过不撤退来活出荣誉文化的期望
when they're confronted by another person, which is exactly what you want to do if you're in an honor culture. When we come back, if people bound by an honor code are willing to retaliate against those who threatened them or threatened their reputations, what happens when people feel they have let themselves down? When their own actions have damaged their reputations.
当他们面对另一个人时，如果你身处荣誉文化中，这正是你想做的。当我们回来时，如果受荣誉准则约束的人愿意对那些威胁他们或威胁他们名誉的人进行报复，当人们觉得让他们自己失望时会发生什么？当他们自己的行动损害了他们的名誉时。
You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. In places where the rule of law is weak, a culture of honor can spring up as a form of self-protection. In such a culture, your security is tied to your reputation and the reputation of your group. You must guard this reputation against all slights, big and small. If you show any weakness, frailty or fear, it's like putting up a big neon sign that says, take advantage of me.
您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain），我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在法治薄弱的地方，荣誉文化可以作为一种自我保护的形式萌生。在这样的文化中，你的安全与你的名誉以及你所在群体的名誉息息相关。你必须捍卫这份名誉，抵御所有大小轻蔑。如果你表现出任何软弱、脆弱或恐惧，就像挂起了一个醒目的霓虹灯招牌，上面写着：占我的便宜吧。
Ryan, I want to talk about a very serious implication of honor culture in the modern United States. You told the story of a friend whose child developed a series of physical texts. The child had Tourette Syndrome. Your friend lived in Oklahoma. Tell me about the conversation you had and the fears he had about this diagnosis going public. So, one of the subtle aspects of honor culture dynamics that my students and I have found over
瑞恩，我想谈谈现代美国荣誉文化的一个非常严重的含义。你讲过一个朋友的故事，他的孩子患有一系列身体抽动症。这孩子患有妥瑞症（Tourette Syndrome）。你的朋友住在俄克拉何马州。请告诉我你们之间的对话，以及他对这一诊断公开的恐惧。所以，我和我的学生们在过去几年里发现的荣誉文化动态的微妙方面之一
the years is connected to this concern about being seen as weak. And it turns out that, and there's a lot of research on this idea, when people have a struggle with mental illness, whatever that particular struggle might be, it might be depression, anxiety, or even something like Tourette Syndrome. Other people, if they're coming from a culture of honor, might see that struggle and view it as a sign of mental instability, mental weakness,
多年来，这与被视为软弱的担忧有关。事实证明，并且有大量关于这一观点的研究，当人们与精神疾病作斗争时，无论这种特定的斗争可能是什么，它可能是抑郁症、焦虑症，甚至是像妥瑞症这样的疾病。其他人，如果他们来自荣誉文化，可能会看到这种挣扎，并将其视为精神不稳定、精神软弱的迹象，
and add extra stigma to it. So again, these are our issues, mental health issues are stigmatized all over the place, all over the world, in are our issues, mental health issues are stigmatized all over the place, all over the world in virtually every community, but honor cultures magnify that kind of stigmatization. So my friends concerned about his son with his terrestrial syndrome, I think was not unreasonable given where he was living in an honor culture and an honor-oriented community.
并为其增加额外的污名。所以再次强调，这些是我们的问题，心理健康问题在各处、世界各地、几乎每个社区都受到污 stigma，但荣誉文化放大了这种污名化。因此，我的朋友对患有妥瑞症的儿子的担忧，考虑到他居住在一个荣誉文化和荣誉导向的社区，我认为并非不合理。
But there's a second element to this that I think complements in kind of a perverse way these honor-related mental health stigmatization issues. And that's that if we see something as a sign of weakness, if it's something that we disparage or despise, then we're not very likely to invest in resources to help deal with that issue.
但这里还有第二个要素，我认为它以一种扭曲的方式补充了这些与荣誉相关的心理健康污名化问题。那就是，如果我们把某事视为软弱的标志，如果我们鄙视或看不起它，那么我们就不太可能投入资源来帮助解决这个问题。
So one of the things that we found in our research is that honor-oriented states in the US invest significantly fewer resources in mental health care. And this creates kind of a perfect storm because you have all these enormous pressures associated with living up to the standards of honor in your honor-oriented community. And then, in addition to that, if you have struggles with these honor-related standards living up to them, you have fewer people to go to. You have fewer resources to draw upon. A note that this next section of our conversation will touch on the topic of suicide. Ryan has looked at the connection between honor cultures and the prevalence of suicide.
因此，我们在研究中发现的一件事是，美国崇尚荣誉的州在心理健康护理方面投入的资源明显较少。这就造成了一种完美风暴，因为你承受着与在崇尚荣誉的社区中达到荣誉标准相关的巨大压力。然后，除此之外，如果你在达到这些与荣誉相关的标准时遇到困难，你可以求助的人更少了。你可以利用的资源更少了。请注意，我们接下来的谈话将触及自杀这一话题。瑞恩研究了荣誉文化与自杀流行率之间的联系。
He tells the stories of two men, both fathers of his friends, who died by suicide. There were very different men. One was very extroverted and outgoing, was a firefighter, and spent his life dramatically saving other people's lives. The other was a sociable but more introverted pastor. Again, he'd spent his life caring for others, but in a less dramatic fashion. This experience of within about a two-year period going to the funerals of these two men really
他讲述了两个男人的故事，他们都是他朋友的父亲，因自杀身亡。他们是截然不同的两个人。一个非常外向、外向，是一名消防员，他的一生都在戏剧性地拯救他人的生命。另一个是一个善于社交但性格更内向的牧师。同样，他一生都在关心他人，但方式不那么戏剧化。在大约两年时间里参加这两个人葬礼的经历确实
inspired me to look more closely into the connection between honor culture and suicide. Honor culture's value reputation above all else and if you lose your reputation you might never get it back you might always live with dishonor. It could make some sense that people who feel like they failed in some important way, or they're deeply anxious about an impending failure that they perceive on the horizon, that they might consider suicide as an escape from dishonor, from shame. So my students and I spent a few years looking at this connection. And what we found was
激发我去更深入地研究荣誉文化与自杀之间的联系。荣誉文化将名誉看得高于一切，如果你失去了名誉，你可能永远无法找回它，你可能永远带着不名誉生活。这就说得通了：那些觉得自己以某种重要方式失败的人，或者对迫在眉睫的失败深感焦虑的人，可能会认为自杀是一种逃避不名誉和羞耻的方式。所以我和我的学生花了几几年时间研究这种联系。我们发现的是
men in particular, women to a lesser extent, who live in honor states, especially if they're white, are significantly more likely to die by suicide. And I think the statistics show that even though suicide affects every race and every age group, middle-aged white men appear to be especially at high risk, and in fact, I believe that risk is growing, perhaps growing especially in honor states. Yes, what we find is that at every age group, white males in honor states are significantly more likely to die by suicide than white males
尤其是男性，女性较少，生活在荣誉州的男性，特别是如果他们是白人，自杀身亡的可能性明显更高。我认为统计数据显示，尽管自杀影响到每一个种族和每一个年龄段，但中年白人男性似乎面临着特别高的风险，事实上，我相信这种风险正在增长，也许在荣誉州增长得尤其快。是的，我们发现，在每个年龄段，荣誉州的白人男性自杀身亡的可能性明显高于白人男性
in non-honor states. But the gap between men in these different regions of the country grows pretty consistently over time. And by the mid-50s, that gap really starts expanding dramatically. So men in the oldest age category of 75 plus are dramatically more likely to die by suicide if they live in honor states versus non-honor states. What's their value based upon now? They're not providers anymore.
在非荣誉州。但美国不同地区的男性之间的差距随着时间的推移相当稳定地增长。到了50岁中期，这种差距真正开始急剧扩大。因此，如果生活在荣誉州与非荣誉州相比，75岁以上最高年龄段的男性因自杀身亡的可能性要大得多。他们的价值现在是基于什么？他们不再是经济支柱了。
They're getting older and frailer. They're going to the doctor all the time so they probably feel physically weak. And it makes a certain amount of sense that they might feel this kind of failure is a reflection of a lack of honor. And consistent with what we see in the case of argument based homicides, this pattern of higher suicide rates in honor states is once again magnified in people living in smaller, more rural communities, where again,
他们日渐衰老和虚弱。他们一直在看医生，所以他们可能会觉得自己身体虚弱。这种类型的失败被认为是缺乏荣誉的反映，这在一定程度上是有道理的。与基于争吵的谋杀案中所看到的一致，荣誉州自杀率较高的这种模式在生活在更小的、更农村的社区的人们中再次被放大，在那里，
everybody knows your name and everybody knows your shame. And some of the statistics on suicide appear to be linked to patterns of gun ownership, but certainly people who use guns to attempt suicide are far more likely to end up killing themselves just because guns are so much more lethal than many other means of suicide. Can you talk a little bit about the patterns of gun ownership and honor culture in the United States? Certainly. And you're absolutely right that gun ownership is closely tied to suicide rates at a community
每个人都知道你的名字，每个人都知道你的羞耻。一些关于自杀的统计数据似乎与枪支拥有模式有关，但当然，使用枪支企图自杀的人最终自杀的可能性要高得多，仅仅是因为枪支比许多其他自杀手段要致命得多。你能谈谈美国枪支拥有的模式和荣誉文化吗？当然。你说得完全对，枪支拥有率与社区层面的自杀率密切相关
level, whether at the county level or the state level, research has shown that the percentage of people with guns in the home is the single best predictor of suicide rates in that community. So what we found is that when we look at suicide rates across different states and we compare honor states to non-honor states or dignity states, that the suicide rates are higher in oner states, even controlling for gun ownership rates. Gun ownership rates, probably not surprisingly, are significantly higher in oner states and they are in non-oner states. And it's interesting, you can actually go beyond just gun ownership and find that the methods people use to commit suicide are actually more violent if they live in honor states. So they're more likely to use a gun, but they're also more likely to use other weapons as
无论是县级还是州级，研究表明，家中拥有枪支的百分比是该社区自杀率的单一最佳预测指标。因此，我们发现，当我们观察不同州的自杀率，并将荣誉州与非荣誉州或尊严州进行比较时，即使控制了枪支拥有率，荣誉州的自杀率仍然较高。毫不奇怪，荣誉州的枪支拥有率明显高于非荣誉州。有趣的是，你实际上可以超越枪支拥有量，发现如果人们生活在荣誉州，他们用于自杀的方法实际上更具暴力性。因此，他们更有可能使用枪支，但他们也更有可能使用其他武器
well. It says, if they're making a statement in the manner in which they take their own life that says, I'm strong, I'm tough, and I'm going out in a dramatic and violent way. I want to spend a few minutes talking about the role of honor culture in politics. Your list of states where there is a strong honor culture include South Carolina, Alabama, Arkansas, Mississippi, and Tennessee, and states that don't include Massachusetts, New York, Connecticut, Hawaii, and Minnesota.
也一样。这就好像他们在以某种方式表明他们选择结束生命的方式时说，我很坚强，我很强硬，我要以一种戏剧性和暴力的方式离开。我想花几分钟时间谈谈荣誉文化在政治中的作用。你列出的拥有强烈荣誉文化的州包括南卡罗来纳州、亚拉巴马州、阿肯色州、密西西比州和田纳西州，而不包括马萨诸塞州、纽约州、康涅狄格州、夏威夷州和明尼苏达州。
It's hard not to see a division there between, you know, prototypical red states and prototypical blue states, Republican states and Democratic states, right? Yes, and there is, in fact, across a variety of studies that we've done, a modest connection between the endorsement of honor-related beliefs and values and political conservatism. It's a consistent and robust connection, but it's not all that strong. I think perhaps a more important way of thinking about how honor and politics are related is not to connect the ideology of honor with any particular political camp, but to think about them as distinct ideological frameworks that can sometimes be combined. So for example, in today's political climate, it's extremely polarized, it's extremely partisan, and
很难不看出其中的分歧，你知道，典型的红州和典型的蓝州，共和党州和民主党州，对吧？是的，事实上，在我们开展的各种研究中，对荣誉相关信仰和价值观的认同与政治保守主义之间存在适度的联系。这是一种一致且稳健的联系，但并不是那么强烈。我认为，关于荣誉与政治如何联系的一个更重要的思考方式，可能不是将荣誉的意识形态与任何特定的政治阵营联系起来，而是将它们视为有时可以结合的不同的意识形态框架。例如，在当今的政治气候下，它极其极化，它极其党派化，并且
climate, it's extremely polarized, it's extremely partisan. And what I see, what I think many people see in the US is that once you've picked a side, if you're a Republican or a Democratic conservative or a liberal, you have a tendency to demonize the other side. You define them as other. They're the bad guys. They're the enemy, even though they're fellow Americans. Once you've demonized your opponent, you've decided they are other. Now they're fellow Americans. Once you've demonized your opponent, you've decided they are other. Now they're the enemy, and if you combine that sort of thinking with the beliefs and values associated with honor culture,
气候，它极其极化，极其党派化。我所看到的，我想美国许多人所看到的是，一旦你选边站队，如果你是共和党人或民主党保守派或自由派，你就有妖魔化另一方的倾向。你把他们定义为异类。他们是坏人。他们是敌人，尽管他们是同胞美国人。一旦你妖魔化了你的对手，你决定他们是异类。现在他们是同胞美国人。一旦你妖魔化了你的对手，你决定他们是异类。现在他们是敌人，如果你把这种思维与荣誉文化相关的信仰和价值观结合起来，
that's a really bad combination. Because what do we do to our enemies in an honor culture? We kill them. We fight them. We get honor to an extent by winning and defeating them. I'm wondering as someone who grew up in the South and grew up in an honor culture and I spent much of his professional life studying it, what do you think today it means or should mean to be a man or a woman of honor?
这真的是一个非常糟糕的组合。因为在荣誉文化中，我们对敌人做什么？我们杀了他们。我们与他们战斗。我们在某种程度上通过赢得和击败他们来获得荣誉。作为一个在南方长大、在荣誉文化中长大并花了很多职业生涯研究它的人，我想知道，你认为今天成为一个荣誉的男人或女人意味着什么，或者应该意味着什么？
I like the idea of loyalty and taking care of the people around me and being that kind of person. Do you think today it means or should mean to be a man or a woman of honor? I like the idea of loyalty and taking care of the people around me and being that kind of person, but other aspects of an honor culture. I don't like so much. I mean, this has been my approach personally, and even the way that I've raised along with my wife are two sons. We want to raise sons who are loyal and who care about and take care of the people around them. We don't want to raise young men who define their worth according to whether they live up to these standards of being tough and brave and intolerant of disrespect.
我喜欢忠诚和照顾身边的人并成为那样的人的想法。你认为今天成为一个荣誉的男人或女人意味着什么，或者应该意味着什么？我喜欢忠诚和照顾身边的人并成为那样的人的想法，但荣誉文化的其他方面。我不太喜欢。我的意思是，这一直是我个人的方法，甚至是我和我的妻子抚养两个儿子的方式。我们想培养忠诚、关心并照顾身边人的儿子。我们不想培养那些根据自己是否达到坚强、勇敢和对不尊重零容忍的标准来定义自己价值的年轻男子。
So it's important to recognize that these beliefs and values can affect you even if you consciously reject them. Because in that way you can take a more deliberative approach to your life and think more objectively and carefully about who you want to be. Ryan Brown is a psychologist at Rice University. He is the author of Honor Bound, how a cultural idea has shaped the American psyche. Ryan, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you, Suncar. It's been great talking with you. MUSIC
因此，必须认识到，即使你理智地拒绝这些信仰和价值观，它们也会影响你。因为通过这种方式，你可以对生活采取更深思熟虑的方法，更客观、更仔细地思考你想成为谁。瑞恩·布朗是莱斯大学的心理学家。他是《荣誉约束：文化观念如何塑造美国心理》一书的作者。瑞恩，谢谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你，尚卡尔。与你交谈非常愉快。音乐
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our production team includes Bridget McCarthy, Christian Wong, Laura Quarelle, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes and Andrew Chadwick. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. Our run song Hero This Week is Alan Henry. Alan is an editor at Wired and a former physicist. He has a knack for making difficult and complicated subjects easy to understand.
《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的制作团队包括布里奇特·麦卡锡（Bridget McCarthy）、克里斯蒂安·王（Christian Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarelle）、瑞恩·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥特姆·巴恩斯（Autumn Barnes）和安德鲁·查德里克（Andrew Chadwick）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。我们这周的主打歌是艾伦·亨利（Alan Henry）。艾伦是 Wired 的编辑，也是前物理学家。他有一种将困难和复杂的主题变得通俗易懂的诀窍。
As we were putting together a recent episode that explored a concept in physics, we found ourselves confused. We panged Alan. He was instantly responsive. He was also gracious and very helpful. A true unsung hero. Thank you, Alan. The episode you've just heard is part of a three-part series looking at how our minds engage with stories.
在我们整理探讨物理学概念的最近一期节目时，我们发现自己很困惑。我们联系了艾伦。他反应极其迅速。他也非常亲切和乐于助人。一个真正无名英雄。谢谢你，艾伦。你刚刚听到的这集节目是一个三部分系列节目的一部分，该系列探讨了我们的心灵如何与故事互动。
If you haven't listened already, please check out the two earlier episodes in the series, which are titled The Story of Stories and The Story of Your Life. If you enjoyed this series please take a moment to tell your friends about us. If your friends are new to podcasting and need help subscribing to our podcast please show them how to do so. I'm Shankar Vedantam. see you next week. you you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你还没听过，请查看该系列的前两集，它们的标题是《故事的故事》和《你人生的故事》。如果你喜欢这个系列，请花一点时间向你的朋友介绍我们。如果你的朋友是播客新手，需要帮助订阅我们的播客，请向他们展示如何操作。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。下周见。你 你 这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。